all right welcome back everyone to my
round five recap from the Qatar Masters
in this game I played International
Master mua from India and my opponent
actually played none other than Magnus
Carlson a few rounds prior I believe it
was round three uh so it was fun to look
at how Magnus beat my opponent and try
and get inspiration from that but in
preparing for this game I realized that
mua can basically play Everything uh I
was looking at E4 on move one and I saw
that he plays celian and kocon and
French and some games with E4 E5 also
some games with PS so I really didn't
know what to expect but I decided to
play E4 and kind of went into the game
thinking that we're just going to play
chess have a battle and uh that's
definitely what happened uh he went for
the Sicilian I played Knight to F3 uh
this deviated from my previous round
against Josiah steerman where I played
Knight C3 and went for a Grand Prix
attack I figured that if my opponent
here is playing Sicilian then I didn't
want to be too predictable and um yeah
Knight F3 is it's a bit less common of a
move for me uh usually I I prefer Knight
C3 on move two but I did have an idea in
mind against uh basically what my
opponent played he went for E6 I played
Knight C3 he played Knight C6 and we
transpose into an open Sicilian after
Queen C7 this is the time manov and this
is actually an opening that I've played
for probably the last 10 to 15 years
from the back side um I've played it on
and off I've definitely mixed things up
over the years but I've enjoyed playing
this position from The Backs side uh
from the white side I don't get this
position too often but it is nice having
experience from the other side cuz I
have a lot of different ideas I can play
and the move I ended up playing here is
a move that I only discovered a few
months ago I was watching the World Cup
in Baku and a good friend of mine Ray
Robson was playing a match against Alex
fur and in his match he got this
position it was I believe his first game
of the World Cup and yeah he played a
move that I didn't even know existed uh
this move being Knight C to B5 and
there's a lot of different moves for
white there's Bishop E3 Bishop E2
there's F4 there's
G3 but Knight cb5 is not a move that I
was at all aware is even playable for
white it looks a little bit strange to
just attack the queen and yeah once
Queen moves back to B8 it seems like A6
is is coming and yeah it seems like
White's just going to be wasting time
moving the Knight again and A6 is almost
always a useful move for black in these
structures uh but the reason why Ray
Robson went for this and the reason why
I went for this is it's an interesting
surprise weapon and it's one way to at
least provoke the opponent to start
thinking early on because it's just
super super rare uh I'll quickly show
the database here yeah you have to look
down pretty far to to find knight
cv5 uh maybe yeah the 10th most popular
move about to explain this move chess
wise the reason for playing this is not
only to get a Tempo on the queen but
it's to
overdefined Play Bishop D3 because it
just hangs a knight so after Knight B5
and then Bishop D3 it's just a different
setup for white that um a lot of players
probably won't be familiar with and my
opponent started to take time here uh he
took about 10 minutes to play Knight to
E7 I will note that if black plays A6 in
this position then I would take on C6
and yeah whatever Pawn takes back I play
Knight C3 um I believe the Ray Robson
game went like dc6 Knight C3 E5 and
Castle I will say that there's a lot of
different branches that both sides can
choose in this opening so I actually
didn't do too much specific preparation
apart from just Knight cb5 and Bishop D3
and after Knight G E7 I was on my own
this is not a move I looked at
beforehand but I still knew opening
principles like I want to develop I want
to Castle and here I started with Bishop
to E3 which does over defend the Knight
and after Pawn A6 I decide to take on C6
first and after he takes back I Retreat
to C3 now I should note that this is
actually a Gambit uh type idea I am
leaving my Pawn on B2 undefended and
black could consider taking it but I
wasn't scared of this during the game
and if black does go for Queen taks B2
my plan was to play Knight A4 hitting
the queen preparing some Knight B6 ideas
and yeah there's a calculation like
Queen B4 I have C3 getting out of check
hitting the queen and defending the
Knight and I thought there's going to be
a lot of compensation with Knight B6
coming and white just has a pleasant
leading development because yeah the
Queen's getting kicked around and all my
minor pieces are developed and pretty
well coordinated too so my opponent did
not take on B2 instead he played Pawn to
D6 I castle and yeah for a few moves the
pawn is just hanging but I don't think
it's ever good for black to take so here
my opponent played Knight to G6 and here
I keep improving with Pawn to F4 and I
figured that this is actually a very
pleasant situation to be out of the
opening like I have very harmonious
development I'm castled and I have now a
nice space advantage in the center and
on the king side now there's ideas of
maybe eventually playing F5 or E5 and
especially if black hassles King side
then there's going to be a lot of
attacking ideas in the middle game so my
opponent plays Bishop to E7 and I start
with a move Queen to H5 and I was very
happy to just have this Square for my
queen and one of the downsides with
having the Knight on G6 instead of
usually the Knight develops to F6 in the
opening um but the downside is the
Knight is not controlling H5 and there's
no G6 to kick the queen away so my queen
is actually very stable on H5 and I
figured later that if black does Castle
then there's ideas of lifting the rook
and um eventually mating like if H6 and
maybe F5 and Bishop takes H6 and just
sack everything and mate so I was
feeling very optimistic here and I was a
little bit surprised that my opponent
decided to Castle after just a couple
minutes of thinking because it seems
kind of risky but I guess it is called
for and it's still a question how I
carry through with an attack and in this
position I decided to play Knight to A4
uh the reason why I didn't go for Rook
F3 is black is is now able to take on B2
and this would be an issue with my rook
and Knight
undefended so I took a moment to play
Knight A4 and not only does this defend
B2 but it has a threat of Knight B6
which I think wins material because if
Rook A7 there's Knight takes C8 and The
Rook would be hit by the bishop so yeah
it's still very uncomfortable for black
in this position and my opponent ended
up playing Pawn to E5 which is
definitely a confrontational move uh he
is challenging my Pawn on F4 and black
is basically dreaming of being able to
trade the pawns and getting a knight to
E5 where this would be a very nice
Central Outpost square but uh I didn't
allow it I played Pawn to G3 now I will
say that F5 was an attractive option but
I wasn't sure about the line with Knight
F4 and I didn't want to trade off my
darks for Bishop to win a pawn um I
think black has enough compensation here
and there is another idea instead of F5
and instead of G3 there's an idea to
play Knight B6 I was actually very close
to playing this move because it does
seem like white wins material but I
didn't play it because I thought that
black maybe has Pawn takes
pawn and yeah I can't take the right The
Rook right away if I move back I thought
there's cases where black will sack The
Exchange and then there's this annoying
Pawn on F4 with Bishop F6 to follow so I
thought G3 kept more attacking options
open and I didn't want to be too
materialistic when there's so much
attacking potential for white in in this
middle game so G3 it was and it's a nice
move reinforcing and restricting this
knight uh my opponent took on F4 I take
back and then he plays Queen to B4 and
this was a bit of a surprise cuz it
seems like the queen is very exploitable
on B4 and this gave me the chance to
play Knight to B6 attacking The Rook
essentially for forcing Rook B8 and then
we get to a very interesting position
where I took a long think here trying to
figure out how to exploit this queen on
B4 because it's very close to being
trapped I do want to note that my queen
does help control the fifth rank so A5
is off limits uh the Bishops also take
away squares from the queen so moves
like C3 and A3 almost tra the queen um
but of course B2 is hanging so it it's
not so easy to win the queen in this
position so I was considering moves like
Rook B1 and I'm not entirely sure why I
didn't go for Rook B1 but I ended up
going for the move Pawn A3 and the
reason why I went for this was there
were some very interesting kind of deep
calculations which I will show but this
move basically forces Queen takes B2 and
I was a little bit surprised cuz it took
him about 7 minutes to play this move
and and I still don't know what else he
was considering but maybe he was just
calculating the the ramifications after
he takes a pawn uh and now I play Rook
to
B1 and what I was expecting in this
position is Queen to F6 and then I was
going to play Knight to D5 which
basically wins material after Pawn takes
E5 Rook takes B8 white goes up the
exchange for pawn and I was trying to
make sense of this position but I'm
pretty sure white is for Choice here
given that I do have the material
advantage and my Bishops are very strong
in the position uh I was calculating a
little bit further Queen E6 I was going
to play Queen D5 and after Queen G4 King
H1 my king would be very safe here Rook
G1 is coming so this is basically the
line I was seeing back from when I
played uh Pawn A3 but we didn't go into
that cuz in instead of playing Queen F6
my opponent played a move which I was
not at all expecting um I was a little
bit concerned when this move came on the
board Knight takes F4 so I was aware of
this idea in other lines where my queen
is counterattacked but I didn't consider
it in this specific line and for a few
minutes I was just staring at this
position trying to comprehend what's
going on cuz there's just so many things
happening with both Queen's attacked the
knight's attacked but my knight is also
vulnerable and the move of course that I
want to play is Bishop takes F4 I should
note I can't take with the Rook because
then my Rook on B1 would hang with check
so I want to play Bishop takes F4 but
then black has Queen D4 check and the
Knight is going to be lost I don't have
Bishop E3 of King G2 Rook takes B6 black
I think is doing okay here I was was
calculating lines of E5 and targeting H7
but then there's G6 so it's just a big
mess after Knight takes F4 and after a
few minutes I came to the realization
that I have pretty nice looking
candidate move Knight takes C8 and after
some time calculating this move it
became pretty clear that this is almost
certainly my best option um I did end
taking the bishop and at first when I
was looking at this position now it's
even more chaotic cuz both Queens are
still hanging my knight is hanging on C8
Black's Knight is hanging on F4 The
Bishop's hanging on E7 just seems like
everything is attacking everything in
this position not to mention there's
ideas of Queen takes B1 to get two Rooks
for the queen and on top of that my
Bishop's attacked there's still ideas of
H7 happening so it's just super super
crazy and sometimes positions like this
you just have to hunker down and
calculate and look at at all the
variations ahead and I concluded here
that in every single variation I'm going
to come out with some material advantage
or some positional Advantage uh because
there's really not too many options for
black uh given that I'm threatening to
take the bishop with check so any queen
move I just take with check I'm going to
be UNM material and the only other
option which happened game is Knight
takes H5 but again I take the bishop
with check forcing King h8 and then I
take the queen and we got to a position
where after the dust has settled a
little bit I have two Bishops for rook
and pawn um but this is by far a
preferable position for white and I'm
pretty sure back when my opponent played
Knight takes F4 I don't think he saw the
issue with Knight takes C8 so once we
got to to this position uh I was feeling
very very good cuz the Bishops are just
going to be super strong in that game
and going forward from here my opponent
played Rook A2 uh trying to win my A3
pawn and it's not the easiest Pawn to
defend but I was very happy with the
resource I came up with I started with
Rook F5 attacking the Knight and after
Knight F6 uh I found a really nice
multi-purpose move Bishop F4 and the
nice idea behind this move is not
[Music]
only items one total $20 MSG huge thank
you to the kindest I am in the world
smile wait
what thanks
um uh I just got distracted by the the
merch alert yeah friendly reminder if uh
if you want to get merch we have coupon
code Qatar save 15% off shop.on
rosen.com
uh I appreciate the the slight
Interruption to this recap uh what was I
saying so the idea with Bishop D4 was
twofold one idea is if Rook takes A3 I
was going to sacrifice the r and there's
a really nice mating idea with my bishop
and Knight just taking away all the
squares from black king So Rook F6 is uh
just a very big threat but not only that
with Bishop D4 I'm controlling the A1
Square so this bishop works on both
sides of the board and because I'm
controlling A1 I have the idea of
playing Rook A5 next and then Knight B4
which would trap The Rook because I'm
taking away all the squares uh from The
Rook on A2 and it turns out that there's
really no good way for black to prevent
both this threat and the threat of Rook
A5 Knight B4 but my opponent tried to
play on he played Knight D7 but after
Rook A5 uh there's really no stopping
Knight B4 so he tried to play Knight C5
hitting my Bishop but I was very happy
to play Knight B4 and after takes takes
I'm now of a piece for just a pawn now
my opponent tried Knight E1 and at first
I thought this move was very clever
because he's attacking my C2 pawn and
he's also threatening to Fork my bishop
and King and when I saw this move coming
I thought I'm going to end up losing
this Pawn but it turns out I just have a
very simple move to keep everything
defended Pawn C3 defending the bishop
getting the pawn to a safe square and
from this moment on um the conversion
was pretty straightforward uh my
opponent did fight he played Rook E8 but
then I take the pawn and he can't take
on e4 because he gets back rank mated so
he played H6 making Loof but I take on
D6 and now I have an extra Pawn on top
of the extra Bishop so life is very good
here uh he takes on e4 and I did have
the chance to take on H6 but then I saw
a different idea of trying to just trap
his Knight I started with King to F2 and
after King H7 I play Knight to B4 and
now my knight and my king worked
together to control all the squares that
this Knight on E1 can move to uh
basically this Knight on on E1 is
completely trapped and this is actually
a common theme uh towards the end of the
game is first Black's Rook got trapped
on A2 and now this Knight is getting
trapped on E1 um but I'm not actually
winning the Knight right away it's just
stuck and uh because the Knight can't
move the Rook is stuck defending it so
going forward from here uh black tried
to storm the pawns but after A4 F5
A5 F4 it looks like I'm just going to
win the race and I was very close to
just playing A6 and trying to queen as
quickly as possible but I saw that
there's some idea of F3 and Rook E2 and
it's winning for white but I didn't want
to take any any sort of risk and I've I
played the move Rook D5 here with
unstoppable idea of Rook E5 to simplify
and after G4 we do Rooks um now now it's
this Rook that has no way of escaping
the trade after takes takes n F3 Bishop
takes F4 my opponent resigned in this
position and this concludes what was my
first win of the tournament this puts me
at 2 and 1 half out of five and I think
overall this was a very pleasant game on
my part I felt like I got the nice
opening surprise got the the nice middle
game attack and my opponent was under
enough pressure in the middle game to um
essentially miscalculate and I think the
end game conversion was very clean so as
usual I have not checked the game with
the engine but I will do some quick
engine
analysis uh now I did forget to make a
new chapter so I guess the first step is
to enable engine
analysis and yeah for anyone that wants
to like do this on leest it's completely
free you just click this button whether
it's uh analysis board or leest study
you do have to give the serers some time
to
Crunch I might have to refresh the
page yeah this way people can see
everything let's try
refreshing
okay wow so I was never worse this
game uh we can
see wait I play the perfect game
really there is some small blip okay
let's go through
so I really play a perfect
game Knight E7 okay Bishop E3 let's keep
going yeah Queen
B2 is is not good for black so that was
a right conclusion and then going
forward yeah it seems like all of this
was very
fine um I'm curious about this
moment now this is
interesting I have a feeling the
engine is not on high enough depth to
like fully understand things although
okay it does say A3 keeps Advantage but
apparently Knight takes C8 was a better
choice and then B3 yeah this is not a
line I considered engine just wants to
play solidly I guess it makes sense to
keep the bishop hair and um just have a
a positional Advantage but A3 was
definitely the more tactical move after
Queen
B2 so black had to play Queen A2 and I
didn't mention this but after the game
my opponent was asking me what I was
going to play against Queen A2 and I
confessed to him that
I didn't actually consider this move but
at the very least I have a draw with
Rook A1 and
repeat but what is the engine saying is
this just a
draw engine saying King
H1 I will say that if if he played Queen
A2 I was going to take time to calculate
here but um I guess I I didn't have to
worry about this
because um yeah Knight takes F4 was
played
and yeah that's just a huge blunder
missing Knight takes C8 apparently Queen
F3 is also winning and rest of the game
was uh yeah pretty
clean so um yeah very satisfying day
again I am 2 and a half out of five uh
tomorrow is a rest day so if you're
watching this recap on October 16th
there's no game um myself and Jonathan
trance will have a break from uh from
the tournament um but do tune in to the
twitch channel on October 17th Jonathan
will be back doing live commentary I
don't know who I'm playing the next game
a parings might go up in the next few
hours but I'm looking forward to getting
more sleep on the rest day hopefully
having some good food maybe I'll try and
take a selfie with a camel I heard
there's camels guitar so yeah stay tuned
for more chess and I'll see you guys
soon